they're like you get a preferred seat
for $30 extra dollar but it's like
what's preferred about it you're like oh
you could recline a little bit more I
know you could do
this for $30 you pay $30 and it's like
hey no elbows and and it's like n I'll
save money and they're like thees are
going body checking you
[Music]
dude okay so American Airlines has sent
a reminder to flight attendants not to
go above and beyond
for passengers in economy what wow
that's crazy that's pretty funny
actually they pay for economy don't
treat them that special they've been
treating us like [__] recently dog I can
feel it doesn't it feel like it's like
oh that was a mandate that makes so much
S I feel like there's like a person
sleeping and there's a blanket that kind
of fell and then the the flight
attendant going like that and the
manager like hey remember we're supposed
to do leave it on the ground spit on
them spit on take it take it she can't
see it she she won know where it went
she so if that was their above and
beyond I wonder what the opposite is cuz
like it's been kind of [__] it's been
[__] I feel like flight attemps have
just getting beaten down the past
[__] like 2 three years too you know
they must be so confused like their
morale you can see in their eyes you're
just like man I feel bad for you bro
like they beat me down I feel like I
need to wear elbow pads every time I'm
in the aisle seek I'm like oh God Jesus
oh yeah when they come with a tray I
feel like they do that on purpose to
slam our [__] elbows it's like
economy economy first class and then
they're you do that every day I mean
yeah probably wouldn't give a [__]
either In First Class it has bumpers on
the
sides dude I still love flying though
like as much as I I I did a I did a [__]
ton of Miles like last year that [__]
don't [__] up your back though uh you
know what I fly so much now I get free
like upgrades to premium economy or
first yeah bro don't ask dumb questions
like that what do you think he is don't
ask a scy [__] for hours I fly Spirit
though like hands down like $20 flights
It's [__] amazing yeah but you travel
with the backpack you cheat you're
cheating oh that's true what do you mean
spirit is $7 for a [__] bag so
normies like me have to use the bag
thing well what you should be doing is
wearing your several days of clothes no
on your person absolutely not put all
the things you need in your backpack you
know how many chains that is he can't
wear I got multiple chains now I got
multiple bags that are [__] crushing
the market what am I going to do you my
friend just don't know how to travel
okay no I know how to brand that's my
problem I know how to Brand look got
eight LED hats all right when you're out
here it's 4 days why would you need more
than a backpack this is $1,000 very big
this $1,000 nft hoodie Joe okay dude
look how much this is oh my God you
could see the ,000 free trade baby all
right trade free now what does that mean
it means I paid $1,000 for it but why
can't you just wear that on your
flight you do put it in your luggage no
I put it in my luggage but I put it
inside of a bag so it's like all nice
and campy and doesn't get hurt retain
the value yeah I got to retain the value
you say you don't wear this in public I
don't wear this anywhere except for to
JK news and that's [__] it and
I wear on crypto corner and that's it
okay and it goes back in the closet look
how pristin it is I'm telling you well
if you want okay we have a we have a
coat rack right there you can put your
stuff here that you can put on while
you're here now that this place is clean
I I will do and whenever you do your
trips okay save money just come with the
clothes on your back
have a stack of stuff here and then just
kind of dig it yeah and then when you're
not here Joe's going to be like look how
good this sweater looks on Jo putting my
chains on
like like what if I turn $88,000 into
$65,000 I would
beol he plays te he role
playing oh that's tight I think my 1,000
Ki turned into 3,000 [__] let's go baby
I think American Airlines need to learn
from [__] the Asian airlines dude oh
my God like Singapore dude Singapore is
incred I'm surprised the [__] won't
blow you yeah they'll do everything bro
my mom was trying to uh get a flight to
Singapore for January that [__] was
round trip [__] like
$5,000 huh round trip round trip is it
cuz it's peak season or something going
is it cuz it's peak season I don't know
first class no that's uh I think either
economy or premium economy that's not
even business that's not even business
dude I got business Singapore Airlines
to Japan round trip for under four grand
that's what me and Nikki did but this
was business 2017 oh yeah when we did
honeymoon to Bali we did Singapore to um
to Bali oh yeah crazy and and uh yeah
four I think five maybe for both of us
for both wow that is really good I don't
even know if those prices are the same
anymore awesome deal actually cuz in
2019 we went to Singapore we got premium
economy that [__] was like $1,300 nice
oh my gosh premium economy premium
economy is worth it in 2019 after that
you know what's funny I could have sworn
premium economy were normal yeah for
real like and then they gave you like
now they like trick you like economy and
you're like really it feels so small and
then you go to premium economy you're
like this is what it used to be yeah I
think they switched it it's a little
bigger right they're just trying to uh
obscure your sense of like what class is
what class cuz spirit what is there even
a first class for Spirit no I think I
think that's on a different plane
entirely no no no no there is their
first class is just play in the front no
they they do have a first class but it's
not it's just bigger seat it's on a
Delta plan I forgot which one it was you
can't even recline yeah like the it's a
fixed chair you're like it's americanl
you're like God damn I got to stay like
this yeah you're sitting like this your
NE is all like they're like you get a
preferred seat for $30 extra dollars but
it's like what's preferred about it
you're like oh you could re a little bit
more I know you can do
this for $30 you pay $30 and it's like
hey no elbows and and it's like I'll
save money and like thees are going body
checking you dude you almost put in
excuse me excuse me excuse me oh sir
you're good what so what ways are they
trying to um cut back on like servicing
so no
blankets uh no uh pillows no treats that
are that could be um seen as confused as
a bit stooping sto and Waffle what do
they give you the [__] the little
cookies bis
offer I heard that the uh airline
industry in America can't survive unless
the government subsidizes it Dam like
it's just that makes sense hard for them
to make a profit spency American uh
framed this as consistency by the way
which is to say that making sure that
there are no occasional surprise and
Delight moments in the coach the heck
taking away the positivity not to take
the liberty of like making anybody's day
a little better no moments of Joy let me
just like read to you what these corpor
crazy if that's the verbage as part of
our commitment to ensuring a consistent
customer experience please refrain from
offering premium cabin amenities SL
service items i e pillows blankets
amenity oh he doesn't want the peasants
to get too used to it but it's under the
guise of equality to anyone not seated
in a premium cabin so basically like
don't let the premium cabin people see
these peasants getting anything close to
what they're getting dude that's some
manipula is that what it is I thought it
was like we just want to keep the same
standard so then they don't expect it
next time when they come what it's both
whatever happened to just making sure
everyone on the plane gets a nice
pleasant ride so then they keep coming
back to the [__] Airline like what
happen to that ni these people have to
be better than these people cuz they
paid more yeah cuz you do want to be
like Oh I'm going to get premium economy
so
stupid dude when I was when I was fing
Singapore though business class I was
laughing at everybody walking by yeah
for sure bye loser Asian airlines though
they make you feel like pu take a shower
[__] out of here you're not staying here
get back here yeah get the [__] out of
here don't use a restroom you know what
I'm wondering like why is it that
they're able to charge like pretty
decent prices but have way better
service and I'm wondering if it has
something to do with like they get they
can afford different um what do you call
it quality
of employment or just it's it's the
price so for example right like in
America the cost of living is really
high right so and then we have unions
and all that stuff so to give everybody
a livable wage it's just so expensive
for American um flights versus like in
Asia the the the living um like standard
living costs are way like chopped down
so they can get away with paying them
less so you know what I mean mean it's
so their prices might be expensive to
the like people in Singapore but like
maybe in America or everyone else buying
the flights are like oh yeah this is
really good this is competitive and then
the quality is high cuz that's for them
all luxury true for Singapore's hell
expensive too though yeah but like let's
say if you live in Tokyo versus a flight
attendant that lives in Oklahoma like
the Oklahoma cost of is probably cheap
oh regionally mean but then like there's
places in Asia that are hell expensive
too like Hong Kong
like when you look at micro region only
huh yeah I still I still think America
even like Oklahoma compared to like
Nagasaki or whatever it's still higher
because so for example in Japan right
like um houses are practically free a
mortgages are like 0% literally dude the
the cost of living is really low outside
of Tokyo so like and you don't need a
car so like in America everyone kind of
needs a car and then a lot of households
have like two right you have by health
insurance so like your monthly expenses
are pretty [__] high and I'm assuming
that's why they can get away the if if
we look at flight attendance payers I I
guarantee you European and Americans are
probably really [__] high got it yeah
um do you have to be a citizen to buy a
house in Japan no no really no he just
made a weeb very
happy no dude all right I know it's like
Italy where there's like they're just
giving